[Applause]
foreign
I see you're glad to see me all right
let's welcome tonight's guests his
Crowds Are like Jesus's tomb on Easter
empty
foundra loved hisparty.com Michael
Lofton
she's got the global radiologist who
won't wear her lead apron Fox News
contributor Dr Nicole Sapphire
he's gathered more facts than a Chinese
spy balloon Fox News contributor and
Washington Times opinion editor Charlie
hurts
and she's got the bark of a rottweiler
but the bite of a pug Fox News
contributor cat Tim
okay before we get to some news stories
it's Friday so let's do this
Greg's leftovers
yes it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and just
like when Greg does it it's my first
time reading these here we go
a late night game of Monopoly in
Brussels reportedly ended in a samurai
sword fight injuring two people
on the bright side experts say it's the
first time anyone has ever finished a
game of Monopoly
it's true
a new study of single people found 44
percent doubt they'll ever find the one
the reason many stop looking for the one
and found the five
yeah that's
that is the perfect Fox News joke
new research is blaming pandemic weight
gains for pushing ten thousand army
soldiers into obesity meanwhile the Air
Force says their study of overweight
Pilots can't get off the ground
[Applause]
hey
the city of Los Angeles has started
blasting classical music at one of its
subway stops to ward off homeless people
and crack down on crime if that doesn't
work they'll try this
what do you want to know I want to give
you I want to give you the opportunity
[Applause]
Disney will be revising lyrics in the
upcoming Little Mermaid reboot to
reflect current sensibilities the movie
will also be labeled dolphin safe
a new report claims that numerous
companies are recruiting seniors in
hopes they'll work harder than young
people although one franchisee walked
back their plan saying I don't know how
it's working out for other restaurants
but it's killing our profits at Hooters
they work hard
[Laughter]
a new survey finds that one in four
allergy sufferers say people accuse them
of Faking it now I don't see what the
benefit of that would be although I did
once fake having hep C to get out of
donating blood
The Late Late Show with James Corden
only has about three weeks left before
ending its run at the end of April but
don't worry if you actually watch the
show it will feel much longer
and finally a new 2024 presidential poll
has Donald Trump now leading President
Biden 47-40 said the first lady I'm just
glad Joe isn't alive to see this
and now to some news Ron ain't screwing
around he's standing his ground yep
DeSantis takes his show on the road
making liberal heads explode Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis spoke to Michigan
Republicans yesterday which means he's
either making a move for the White House
or hatching his own plan to kidnap
Gretchen Whitmer
DeSantis tooted his own horn expertly
which is no easy feat when Biden does it
he sprains his back
among Ron's successes stripping Disney
World of its self-governing status and
stopping wokism dead in its tracks you
know at the end of the day it may have
been the case that Disney ran the State
of Florida for the 60 years prior to me
being Governor but they do not run it as
long as this Sheriff's in town
and Ronnie ain't done yet he put Disney
on notice because they tried to pull a
fast one on the way out the door
they tried to pull a fast one on the way
out the door they've been caught on that
so all I can say is that story is not
over yet buckle up there's going to be
more coming down the pike
buckle up or pull the crossbar securely
over your waist and shoulders
in town says the story is not over yet
the same thing Disney will say after Toy
Story 11.
Charlie uh what do you think can you
tell me what's going on here what did
Disney do I tried to read this legally
uh but basically he tried to put a new
board over the Disney uh ruling Zone
down there and they kind of pulled a
fast one yeah no I mean if you get into
the weeds it's incomprehensible and it
all goes back to Charles King Charles
yeah uh it's very confusing and I I
wouldn't recommend but I will say this
uh like basic politics Disney is doing
Rhonda said it's a huge favor here by
keeping the story alive as long as Ron
DeSantis has Disney to to browbeat over
uh sexualizing children and teaching uh
you know this uh creepy stuff to young
children uh Rhonda Santos has something
to talk about and it's it's very popular
it's very popular among Republicans but
I it's also very popular among
Independents and I think even some
Democrats so whatever Disney's up to
they're actually helping Rhonda Santos
yes they're keeping the fight alive Dr
Sapphire plus the Mandalorian kind of
stinks now now doesn't it hey you know I
have three sons and several of them
watch the Mandalorian they like that but
you know I have two issues when it comes
to this whole Disney DeSantis thing
first of all I have a huge problem with
these large corporations a Disney coming
out and taking these political stances
as though everyone who works there
agrees with what they're saying and as
though anyone who wants to go visit
Disney feels the same way they need to
stop doing that I can tell you there are
conservatives who work at Disney but
they feel bullied discriminated and they
have to literally work in seclusion
because they're worried for their jobs
believe me they're there but on the
other side you have Disney who came in
six decades ago they were given this
deal to be essentially a Sovereign
Nation within Florida because no one
wanted to be in Orlando and now you
can't do that now 60 years later in the
most populated or most popular state of
Florida and just say I'm the mayor here
and I'm going to continue to govern you
can't do that so DeSantis is going to
win this fight and all you have to do is
fax matter more people are moving to
Florida and up in Michigan where you
have Governor Whitmer people are leaving
they've left continuing for the last
three years that's right and Cat I mean
there's more than just Disney down there
there's lots of other theme parks and
everything so Disney better kind of wise
up they're not always going to be on top
down there but even if it made sense at
one point maybe in the 60s uh you know
50s I don't know when they started
Disney 60s down there maybe it made
sense at the beginning give them a
little extra room let them run things
but now that Florida I mean there's a
there's a lot going on down there why
should we leave the governing up to
Disney
okay so I have a perspective on this
that's going to be unpopular with
everyone so you guys Buckle yeah that's
actually hate Disney so much Disneyland
place just as it I've gotten in trouble
saying how much I hate it
um they're with you I'm also not a tax
attorney so whenever taxes are involved
I believe taking someone's money without
consent is immoral on its face when it
comes to this I think there is a bit it
kind of started because Disney said
something about uh some of Rhonda
Sanders's legislation that he didn't
like I am concerned that
um just about the idea of a government
retaliating in some way against the
speech of of somebody right but and the
larger picture this is where I just I
feel like I'm crazy if I'm alone on this
I don't get as wrapped up in the culture
War stuff as people on the left and the
right seem to do I think that they
scream at each other about it they
scream at it about each other I don't
like to sexualize children I also as an
adult enjoy RuPaul's Drag Race but it's
a great show but meanwhile I'm just like
hey guys like is the dollar going to
you know a fighting like a world war
three is that gonna happen uh you know
the the restrict act coming up are we
going to lose all this even more of our
rights and freedoms with some of this
legislation that's being discussed so
that's where I'm at and you know where
to send my hate because you already do
hi think they like that cat makes some
good cow
so you just
that's it Michael cat just wants to
focus on the bigger issues yeah she's
sick of this culture War stuff but I
think you love the culture right well to
me you know something's gone off the
rail when Disney's coming after the kids
right like something's really gone
fundamentally wrong like they're
changing the words to the songs in a
Little Mermaid soon the rides will be
different you know you'll have the
spinning gender fluid teacups
in whichever way your kid stumbles into
oh she's a boy
[Laughter]
and if DeSantis really wants to go after
Disney all he has to do is get like get
the Department of Justice and the FBI
involved by saying Trump loves Disney
[Laughter]
he's there every weekend they'll be
jumping off that freaking Castle just
arresting old ladies in the middle of
the night it's so true it is true
it's a it's a thing the uh Charlie you
wanted to get in here you got more but
cat makes a great point and I I think
actually that you uh what you just said
sort of reflects what most people feel
but but because of our politics are so
screwed up now you have Democrats who
are embracing these crazy agenda uh
pieces of agenda and um and and you know
not long ago Florida was considered a
swing state it's not a swing state
anymore
um but when you have uh Democrats
embracing policies uh that increase
crime uh like defund the police when you
have Democrats embracing uh illegal
immigration you have all of these issues
that are 90 10 issues among most people
but as soon as they get like like
squeezed down into our political
discussion they suddenly become like 50
50 issues and they're not 50 50 issues
nor should they be and that's why Ron
DeSantis has done so well in Florida is
by identifying those issues and just
talking about them yeah outside of the
realm of politics exactly before we go
Greg's going on tour to promote his new
book and I'm going with him the book is
the king of late night check out this
preview
all right gut field at the house
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that's it
we're heading up Atlanta cities in
Florida Rhode Island Pennsylvania go to
gutfeld.com for tickets before it's too
late and up next a green CEO suggests
your property must go
if you'll be in the New York area and
would like free tickets to see Gutfeld
go to foxnews.com Gutfeld and click on
the link to join our studio audience
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else